a deceiving calm as the edge of a
community crumbles into the sea
Daniel runs the Lifeboat service here
now out of action and the beach is
closed after two nights of high winds
and Tides tore into the coast it just
seems there's no matter of urgency to
anything along this Coastline and how
urgent is it all right surgeon to me
I've said this needs to do it now not in
two years time this should have been
done five years ago we've lost so much
of this coastline
homes are at risk too a quarter of
Mary's back Gardens being lost to the
Sea
but to move out
but um
we took our chances
if it Carries On
I call it I don't know how long I don't
know it depends on who helps and who
doesn't
need someone to help us
in 30 years hemsby beach has lost around
100 meters a telegraph Pole now Teeters
on the edge
the geology of some areas makes them
more vulnerable than others here on the
east coast of England it's particularly
at risk because it's made up of a
mixture of soft clay and sand Which is
less resistant than the harder rock
found over in the west now it's an
inevitability erosion has always
happened but what's different is the
process is accelerating and many believe
that that is down to climate change
the amount of government money allocated
to Coastal erosions risen but there's a
feeling action isn't in step with the
urgency of a changing landscape we have
sea levels that are rising faster now
because of global warming and that means
that we will see more of this kind of
thing happening in the future but I
would emphasize that this is as much a
problem with a communication problem a
planning problem a question of having
honest conversations in communities so
that people understand what's going on
coastal areas like this one want and
emission and an acceptance we can't turn
the tide of erosion Adele Robinson Sky
News Norfolk